oh don't youtube recently I'm gonna copy
this in guys I like to play about girls
but there are funny and [ __ ] the guys
dude that are not nice
let me tell you something I agree guys
have some annoying habits and traits
that they always do that are [ __ ]
annoying I get it I understand I'm a
knight but there are so many that I
can't even begin to count so let's just
start with a few so y'all know what it
is
the some reason God talk [ __ ] about
another girls look when they ugly [ __ ]
themselves
that's ugly all of the crowd [ __ ] you
should go to jail for that I don't know
why for some of the most hideous dudes
will tell the circle look at a girl and
be like boom bust it for some reason I
feel like guys like to talk [ __ ] about
somebody house in order to make them
feel better about themselves well guess
what my turn let's do a job what look is
stupid Lion King Rafiki ass heaven face
ya dumb [ __ ] talk about how ugly
somebody else's I bet you when you were
born your mama with the church to ask
God for a receipt you ugly-ass fun
looking like a mix between Rosie
O'Donnell and Yoda yeah
yes but these same scrubs will sit
around a circle and talk about fine ass
women - yeah go do [ __ ] like you sitting
over there touching your dick saying
[ __ ] like that [ __ ] hello father
I've taken to the backend
that [ __ ] all black me that's the only
thing you ask is that hairy ass back of
yours and alright know what you gonna
say what Judy I'll say that [ __ ] to a
face I'll say to a right now know your
office if you got any comes to where she
would run the [ __ ] away you sasquatch
looking like a National Geographic
special yeah you just look like a sexual
predator the olive knows that some who
just have like a permanent ugly creepy
face it's like an ugly sweater they
could never take off my meal and you
could let us know what a beautiful woman
is walking by but stop lying and
bragging about all the crazy ass [ __ ]
that you might do two more like flip
around also the crazy [ __ ] cuz we all
know if you could get someone like that
you would be in the middle of a parking
lot another thing that guys like dude
they love to talk about their sexcapades
your penis found the [ __ ] vagina look
did you you know with the we're [ __ ]
against every single dude that slept
around who's a ho himself wants to fight
a girl that wasn't a ho either what
double-standard [ __ ] uh-oh here any
decent woman isn't gonna want a god who
got his dick was a lost sheep try to
open up every single door in the
tri-state area
get your [ __ ] together mr. McCain yeah
this may not be something that God does
but it sure [ __ ]
something that got done to think about
hygiene is important fellas bottle me
remember this big-ass kraut you live in
a [ __ ] garbage can watch yourself and
please don't use this excuse how long
use then actually smell too good a dumb
[ __ ]
yo it smells too curly [ __ ] you
that whole manly spelling [ __ ] is oh and
that's what people say years ago you
know why they didn't have running water
some of you do smell so bad you smell
like a skunk they got [ __ ] it out of it
already taste [ __ ] so I'm gonna even
fly be going up to you like this is it
oh my god the [ __ ] is that smell
our most bit aware of these things no
because I think what they would probably
stop it personally do I do any of these
annoying things hell no and you know why
because once you get pepper sprayed like
27 times in the eye you learn from your
lessons tell yourself I got sprayed so
much I'm immune to that [ __ ] [ __ ] that
she don't even wear it smell like spicy
potpourri
[Music]
into the water and shred when you laugh
this muscle of the muffler hanger and a
half [ __ ] my house of [ __ ] what [ __ ]
boom bust is [ __ ]